I heard Sergey is in there writing the
code right yeah Sergey needs a Johnny
eye he was the one that pushed for the
release apparently oh really let's go
yeah I like Serge after dark I mean he's
worth a 100 billion his writing code I
so much respect for Samurai Sergey oh I
like the new Nick Samurai Sergey he's in
the game oh yeah somebody sent this
message to Samurai zge I I know him
please hire your Johnny ey find a
branding person and stop taking Google's
Innovations and wrapping them in bad ux
this is a place to invest like literally
just find 10 great designers put them in
a room don't let anybody near him well I
think Johnny IV has a studio now he
could just acquire it yes go get I mean
go give Johnny I a billion dollars and
and have him come in for 10 hours a week
he'll do a better job than the Google
team no offense all respect to the
Google team